[Applause]
[Music]
catastrophe has just come to an end and
the show masterfully sent our characters
off with what could arguably be one of
the best final seasons of a show ever
the touching episode contained a
heartbreaking tribute to Carrie Fisher
and all round felt like an amazing
send-off not only to the lay actress but
also the rest of the characters
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the finale as well as my thoughts
on it there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want to know anything
about the last episode of the show then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
but without the way and definition and
welcome to the channel where I watch it
so you don't have to
in case you're watching this just to see
what the Carrie Fisher tribute was and
aren't fully up to speed here's
catastrophe in a nutshell catastrophe is
a comedy that stars Rob Delaney as Rob
and Sharon Hogan as Sharon after the
latter falls pregnant when the former is
on a business trip to the UK the two
decide to give it a go and start a
family with one another the show follows
all the highs and lows of their
relationship and is beautifully acted
with an amazing undertone of black
comedy to it it's really a picture
perfect example of a dysfunctional
family there's very much a masterpiece
of modern storytelling and the final
episode was no different anyway in that
final episode the pair and their
children went to Boston on holiday to
discover that Rob's mother Maya played
by Fisher had suddenly passed away well
it's official wasn't a massive element
of the show she still provided a lot of
heart to it and behind the scenes there
were rumors that the writers were having
trouble handling her characters absence
in it the send-off couldn't have been
better though and in the finale at her
funeral Rob read out a letter that the
character had written about Mike Pence
it stated that I heard about these
babies their spines like corkscrews but
once they have these surgeries it's
beautiful I wouldn't have to do it at
all if the government gave a rat's ass
about disabled kids they'd be happy to
throw them out the window
I bet Mike Pence spends his Sunday's
strong disabled kids out of windows
looks like you would that effing
microwaved Apple looking ass
mother effer her obviously those who are
aware of carrie fisher's outspoken
personality know that the actress would
have loved this and fans were quick to
go to Twitter to point out just how
perfect this send-off was for her this
show was pretty blunt and this excellent
dark humor magically sums up her
incredibly dark personality Mike Pence
is of course the current US
vice-president and it's pretty clear
exactly what the creators of the show
think of the current administration and
its policies there are more bombshells
dropped after we learn that Sharon has
once again pregnant and that Rob wants
to move the family to Massachusetts the
to have a massive argument that's
similar to the ones in the show that
we've come to love and hey but
eventually they make up and Sharon says
she'd consider moving to the country the
two then go to the beach and after
leaving their children sleeping in the
car decide to go and sit down
Sharon throughout the episode has really
went back and forth on their
relationship but she lovingly tells Rob
that she still wants his baby and it's
pretty much the perfect summation of the
show they question whether they would
still be together if you hadn't felt
pregnant and it's just a nice final
chapter for the two that shows how
amazing and catastrophic their life
together has been Sharon then strips off
and runs into the sea which is when Rob
notice is a sign that warns of dangerous
currents in the area as well as rip
tides he calls out to warn her before
glancing at his car and then strips of
himself and runs in after her it's not
the big rescue that you'd expect though
and the two kiss in the sea as they
float away from the shore and you can
kind of tell that they're really
struggling to swim back to it but it
doesn't really matter to me this
incredible final shot of them adrift at
sea sums up their entire relationship
together they were tossed into a
situation where they would have to swim
against the current to survive and even
though as a whole it's pretty hopeless
and they'll probably never reach their
goals
they're still trying on the shore is the
picture s life that they've always
wanted but they ignored the warning
signs and when added together to really
make a go of it against the odds it's so
symbolic and pretty much the best
metaphor that the creator is gonna be
use for the show and basically I
absolutely loved it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the finale and if you thought it was
a fitting send-off comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my video on everything that
you need to know before you watch the
Umbrella Academy which will be linked at
the end this is a channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]